le montant de la dette et du déficit
reste un mystère
seule certitude la clinique sainte-marie
est bel et bien en cessation de paiement
la direction a informé officiellement
les organisations syndicales de la
situation économique de l'établissement
cette semaine une catastrophe prévisible
selon les représentants cdmt la majeure
partie des fournisseurs ne sont pas
payés pour l'instant et étant donné que
nous sommes en cessation de paiement
effectivement eu nouveau aucun centime
depuis 2006 nous avons ainsi reculé à
l'ogre capa qui n'a rien fait de la
clinique sainte marie
ils ont plongé la clinique dans le liant
en entraînant le personnel avec lui
voilà le plan social s'impose donc
32 des 174 salariés sont déjà concernés
par les mesures drastiques inhérentes à
la chute de la clinique sainte marie
certains disent que c'est par une voix
pas très légal que la direction leur a
communiqués leur sort j'ai appris lundi
j'étais en train de regarder les rênes
du shopping j'entends mon téléphone et
je réponds il me dit oui je vous
apprends que vous avez vous n'êtes pas
sur la liste des lices aussi donc je
trouve que c'est un des acteurs et la
pac tacle on apprend quelques après 38
ans de service qu'il est licencié je
pourrais pop aurait pu me suicider fait
une dépression faire n'importe quoi donc
moi j'ai très mal pris ça une maternité
fermée depuis quelques semaines pour
cause de mort suspecte
ce matin les organisations syndicales
ont invité la direction en assemblée
générale la presse n'était pas conviée
le directeur devait annoncer lui même au
personnel les graves difficultés de la
clinique